mark this film is really powerful it's
also terrifying why why was this a story
you felt needed to be told well when I
read it in the New York Times Magazine I
I I was so blown away by it by the by
the depth and the scope of it and I
couldn't believe that I wasn't reading
about it on the cover the New York Times
that it wasn't on the cover of every
major publication in the world and at
that time I was looking for stuff to
produce and this really sat well within
my activism and political work and
environmental work and I realized also
like how powerful films are for getting
out information if you can make it good
and entertaining and moving it could
have a profound impact and could teach
people that they've been poisoned and
we're completely left out of the
decision of that poisoning it's also
dramatic when you say it that we have
been poisoned but that that fact that
comes up in the film that all of us 99%
of us me and you sat here now have this
forever chemical PFOA in our bodies yes
this is crazy and this flight is still
going on right this isn't something so
this classic chemicals are still
unregulated even though the biggest
Health Study in human history 70,000
people was done on this chemical it's
the most studied chemical in the history
of chemicals it's definitively linked to
seven different major diseases
testicular cancer and kidney cancer we
still don't have any regulations and
it's an outrage and the only reason we
don't is because we didn't know what was
happening but now we do and thanks to
rob a lot in this beautiful community of
people who fought for 20 years to to get
justice and
to have their story told we were able to
make dark waters and able to tell the
rest of the world what every major
publication and the world should have
done 10 years ago but failed to do it's
like a really urgent parallel here with
the climate crisis going on right now
you know the waters and the earth being
polluted obviously America the most
powerful country in the world should be
leading this fight but your president is
not a believer in climate crisis how do
you feel about this I think the world
should consider my president as public
enemy number one at this point what we
do probably in the next ten years will
be crucial to the future of the planet
and this is only going to become more
and more evident to us we're not we're
not going backwards from here and yeah
it's it's not just this story this is a
system there's no superheroes in this
world is there but Greta Tom Berg does
she
there are superheroes you know there's
Rob a lot there's Greta
there's the instinct extinction
rebellion these people it's happening
all over and we have to make people
uncomfortable we're gonna have to get
radical we're gonna have to do peaceful
peaceful demonstration peace peaceful
protests peaceful actions that that are
that stopped this system